cool adorable yes if I recall you by
Rachel anyway let's get into it
hello reject nation i'm greg alba with
me today is adorkable rachel adorkable
rachel right now is actually marathoning
the MCU films in order to prep for
infinity war for her viewing experience
i have one left and ironically he's
wearing the perfect shirt for it today i
just need to wide slack pants late yeah
go back and revisit it and then talk
more about it on my stardust app and
everything yeah that's how we met was
actually through a stardust event that
took place and so you follow the stars a
beautiful adorable Rachel on YouTube
where she does reactions and movie
reviews as well she's the perfect person
to feature on the real rejects today and
I thought it'd be fun since you're
watching all these movies to do a
trailers revisited with you John and I
actually just did our Avengers infinity
war non-spoiler movie review which has
an opening sketch at the beginning of it
guys would love for you guys to go check
it out people do that after Batman
homecoming this trailer was sent to us
and what we do our trailers revisited
it's more about the analysis we
determine how accurately portray was the
movie did he get the tone ride does a
spoil too much what things did they
leave to a surprise that we're glad was
left out of the trailers I think
homecoming was pretty popular for being
pretty spoiler worthy and its trailer
probably i love spider-man in general so
I felt like I was watching a very true
spider-man because the total McGuire
movies were pretty good and Andrew
Garfield is like this one I was like
yeah this feels like the spider-man that
I would want him to be on the big screen
yeah I agree
he's probably the best fighter round
we've ever had well guys let's check out
the trailer then we'll talk about it do
it this is this second trailer this is
the one that sent over by several people
[Music]
[Music]
forget the flying monster day there are
people who handle the ATR for that
I love that its eyes move yeah this
trailer is pretty spoiler heavy I mean
obviously they want to get people like
the first hour no surprise when I saw
that movie I'm gonna need to shoot back
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have I know you know what I'm
talking about
I'll kill you and everybody there blood
the guy who's still out there I've just
got to do this on my own it's bringing
back a lot of memories
yeah just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah what if I'm fascinating
about watching this trailer again is
it's bringing back everything that I was
able to kind of pick up on and decode on
how the movie would play out ultimately
and so I thought the trailer was
probably incredibly spoiler heavy the
first time I watched it revisiting in
the trailer I'm kind of like it's still
spoiler heavy but not as thick and
spoilers as I thought it would be
actually I remember when I saw the movie
and after the ferry scene with Iron Man
and spider-man and he was saying oh I
know that it's not really you justice
soon you're just a robot
whatever you said it was like yeah it is
because I saw the trailer yeah I saw him
walk out of the suit like that
particular was like not a surprise at
all like yeah I know that's actually
Tony Stark especially because I have an
earlier scene where Ironman does show up
and just the suit and then he doesn't
reveal the show he's not really there
yeah when he first saves him I mean this
trailer does pretty much beat out a lot
of the movie for you he's just a
friendly neighborhood spider-man he
wants to be an Avenger Tony Stark's not
letting him something goes wrong with
the ferry would try to take down vulture
Iron Man takes away the suit from
spider-man because he's not worthy then
Spiderman gets a little depressed
embodies his old suit and then tries to
take down the vulture on his own there
yeah you piece it all together right
there was gonna be something that
happens to the suit because as we saw in
the trailer he's like in a very intense
scene he's just wearing the mock-up
version yeah suits and that's a majority
of the movie like a bunch of big plot
points I think we're taking out there
because that doesn't happen till like
halfway through the film where he loses
the suit yeah I might even been like
close to the all's lost moment of the
film but like a little bit before the
finale when he's like all depressed
about not having the suit in yeah he's
trying to get his life back in order so
it does give you a good chunk of the
movie I'm glad that there's a few things
they don't give away like that's
especially dramatic I think because it
hits so closed and he cares so much
about this girl and the villain is the
dad doing a surprise surprise I'm so
glad they didn't even come close to
hinting that in here yeah so any of that
yeah I'm so happy that they didn't do
that it's like they gave away a lot of
how the plot would play out I think one
thing the tone that's kind of not
communicated in the trailer I would have
like to be communicated is how funny the
movie is yeah cuz the movies hilarious
yeah it's a really really funny movie
and I think Marvel can do that often
give you like serious trailers for
movies that are actually really funny
and I think spider-man homecoming one of
its subgenres is comedy but they're
giving us such like an epic serious
trailer with hints of humor like maybe
his friend Ned will be funny maybe Peter
Parker will have a few funny lines but
the tone of this trailer is super
serious and I don't feel that the movie
feels like the way the trailers
seriousness here a bit humor in there I
mean I love that Spiderman to me in this
movie I mean we always know that he's
been a bit of a jokester but to me he
was like the downplayed Deadpool you
know in the movie which is fine and I
wish we could have maybe seen a little
bit more on the trailer because I think
that would have encouraged people to see
like oh yeah this is good because the
movie has that kind of teen high school
John Hughes vibe about it but that's not
really being conveyed is this specific
trailer I think there was an earlier
trailer that kind of gets that point
across but this one not so I do like to
believe a lots of surprise especially
with Ned and Peter Parker their
relationship I think was a big take away
from the film that I don't think a lot
of people were expecting was like yeah
like that quality is not really in the
trailer too much and I like that they
left a lot of that to surprise
ultimately in the end although again it
wasn't that big of a surprise when he
was crawling into his room that was so
funny if that was a surprise to that's
what I mean they give away like a lot of
what the action scenes will probably be
but I think it's the finale that they
don't really give away at all I kind of
forgot in the movie that it's called
spider-man homecoming while they're
building up to homecoming
I wasn't expecting him to just leave
homecoming yeah the ending scene where
they all go home come yeah it's an
interesting title though even to this
day I'm just like man what a unique
title yeah
spider-man homecoming but it also kind
of I know it's like links to the comics
and it's kind of like a meta title for
you know spider-man
being inducted into the MCU officially
to homecoming
but another thing that I thought to try
to does really well is like they have
that little spider come out of him when
he's on the Washington Monument and
they're like the web the way they tease
that the suit will be upgraded what they
don't tease is that there'll be a voice
in his head and the suit will have way
more capabilities than what they're
actually teasing in the tree yeah yeah
yeah this soon is definitely more
advanced than we're used to but they
don't give away everything about me yeah
I thought that was a nice surprise was
suits incredibly more high-tech because
I thought I wish they'd say that way
spider but then he watched me really
action in spoil yeah they just teased it
I think overall it's a good trailer I
mean would I have liked more humor most
definitely paterna's making something
it's a heavy weighty film when it's not
what I would like to have cut down some
of the plot point sure but overall I
mean yeah it's a good trailer it's a
little misrepresented sure but it is job
five sold a bunch of tickets and yeah
people went saw it when it's not they
well I think the best way some of this
shows it feels more like Sony cut this
trailer together then Marvel cut this
trailer together yeah I think this is
how Sony cuts or spider-man trailers
together alright guys well hey this was
fun
thanks for being here Rachel thanks for
having me you can subscribe to the real
rejects become a part of the reject
nation click that notification about to
get notified every time one of our vids
is up adorable Rachel on YouTube make
sure to follow her adorable Rachel on
Twitter I mean a dork a buddy
that's dude that's your quote that's
your catchphrase come being a dork the
buddies I call my fans my adore kabadi a
dork a buddy yeah that's cute yeah it's
adorable
thank you description box please follow
her thanks for being here guys nyeeehhh